Herzlichen Glückwunsch!
Sie haben im Lotto gewonnen! Einhundert Millionen Euro im Jackpot.
Toll oder?
Nein.
Tatsächlich tatsächlich hätte ihnen kaum was schlimmeres
passieren können.
Bestimmt hast du auch schon mal von Leuten
gehört, die ihre großen Gewinne innerhalb
von kürzester Zeit verspielt, verschwendet
oder verloren haben.
Leider stehen die Chancen gar nicht schlecht,
dass dir genau das gleiche passieren wird.
Eine Studie des Harvard Colleges hat herausgefunden:
je mehr Geld du im Lotto gewinnst, desto höher
ist die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass du in den
nächsten 3 – 5 Jahren pleite gehst.
Ist doch eigentlich paradox, oder?
Die wenigsten Menschen gehen im Alltag pleite,
aber sobald jemand viel Geld bekommt, steigen
die Chancen dafür extrem.
Vielleicht liegt es an den Leuten, die Lotto
spielen.
Klar, Glücksspieler sind wahrscheinlich nicht
die verantwortungsvollsten Menschen, wenn
es um Geld geht.
Vielleicht geht es hier aber auch um Geld
und Gier an sich.
Denn viel Geld zieht auch die Aufmerksamkeit
von vielen neidischen Blicken auf sich.
Was solltest du also tun, falls du wirklich
einmal das Pech haben solltest, im Lotto zu gewinnen?
Herzlich Willkommen, zu einem neuen Video auf Doktor Whatson!
Und vergesst nicht den Kanal zu abonnieren,
um kein neues Video zu verpassen!
2002 hat der US-Amerikaner Jack Whittaker
den damals größten Jackpot der US-Geschichte gewonnen
315 Millionen Dollar.
Schon vor dem Gewinn war Whittaker eigentlich
finanziell sehr gut aufgestellt.
Er hatte eine erfolgreiche Firma, war verheiratet,
hatte Kinder und Enkelkinder.
Das heißt, er konnte mit Geld umgehen und
hatte Leute um sich herum, denen er vertraut
hat.
Und so lebte er glücklich bis an sein Lebensende...
Naja, nicht wirklich.
Denn nachdem sich Whittaker seinen riesigen
Lotto-Gewinn hat auszahlen lassen, ging alles
ganz schnell bergab.
Da er seinen Gewinn öffentlich entgegengenommen
hat, wurde er von Stalkern, Leuten mit kuriosen
Geschäftsideen oder alten “Freunden”,
die dringend Geld brauchten regelrecht belagert.
Er stellte allein drei Leute an, um seine
Post zu sortieren.
Doch die Leute klingelten bald bei ihm Zuhause.
So war er gezwungen Sicherheitsleute zu bezahlen,
um seine Familie zu beschützen.
Danach verkehrte Whittaker mehr und mehr in
örtlichen Strip-Clubs.
Einen Teil seines Gewinns hatte er immer bei
sich.
So wurde ein Jahr später in sein Auto eingebrochen.
Hier erbeuteten Diebe knapp 550.000 Dollar.
Auf die Frage hin, warum er so viel Geld mit
in den Strip Club nehmen würde, antwortete
er nur: Weil ich es kann.
Kurz darauf wurden zwei Mitarbeiter des Strip
Clubs verhaftet, als sie versucht haben Whittaker
zu vergiften.
Nur ein Jahr später wurden durch einen zweiten
Einbruch weitere 200.000 Dollar erbeutet.
Zu dieser Zeit hat Whittaker sein Geld noch
schlau angelegt.
Seine Firma hat sich verdoppelt und er spendete
14 Millionen Dollar für wohltätige Zwecke.
Trotzdem nahmen tragische Ereignisse ihren
Lauf.
Seine Familie und Menschen in seinem Umfeld
wurden Opfer von mehreren Drogen-Unfällen.
Dann ist auch noch seine Tochter gestorben.
Kurz danach hat sich seine Frau von ihm getrennt.
Heute ist Whittaker bankrott und schwer verschuldet.
Das ist wirklich eine tragische Geschichte…
aber vielleicht hatte Whittaker einfach nur
Pech?
Oder sich ein bisschen blöd angestellt?
Du oder ich würden natürlich viel schlauer
mit unseren Gewinnen umgehen.
Und ich meine, das ist ja nur ein Beispiel,
richtig?
Falsch.
Billie Bob Harell, Jr.
Gewann 1997 31 Millionen Dollar.
Nur zwei Jahre später nahm Harell sich das
Leben nach endlosen Betellein durch Freunde
und Familie.
»Die Lotterie zu gewinnen ist das schlimmste,
was mir jemals passiert ist«, so soll er
noch gesagt haben.
William Post hat 1988 16 Millionen Dollar
gewonnen.
Ein Jahr später beauftragte sein Bruder einen
Auftragsmörder, um ihn und seine Frau zu
töten und so ans Erbe ranzukommen.
Er kam zwar mit dem Leben davon, ging aber
später bankrott und landete im Gefängnis,
nachdem er auf einen Schuldeneintreiber geschossen
hatte.
1996 gewann Jeffrey Damper 20 Millionen Dollar.
Zehn Jahre später wurde er von seiner Schwägerin
und ihrem Mann entführt und ermordet.
Und das ist nur ein kleiner Teil der Schicksale
vieler Lotto Gewinner.
Was uns endlich zu der großen Frage bringt:
Was solltest du tun, falls du einmal das Pech
haben solltest im Lotto zu gewinnen?
,,JACKPOTT"
Und die überraschenden Antwort lautet: Erstmal
gar Nichts.
Dein größter Feind im Falle eines Gewinns
bist du selber.
Direkt am ersten Tag deinen Job kündigen,
ein teures Auto zu bestellen und deinen Gewinn
auf Facebook posten ist wahrscheinlich keine gute Idee.
Nicht einmal deiner Familie und deinen engeren
Freunden solltest du es erzählen.
Zumindest noch nicht.
Als erstes suchst du dir am besten einen Anwalt.
Nicht euren örtlichen Familien-Anwalt, der
dir geholfen hat, das Geld für dein geklautes
Fahrrad zurückzubekommen.
Nein, am besten jemand den du noch nie gesehen hast
und jemand, der niemanden aus deinem Umfeld
kennt.
Am besten fährst du in die nächste Großstadt
und suchst dir eine der Top Kanzleien des
Landes heraus.
Die kannst du dir jetzt leisten.
Zusammen mit deinem teuren Spitzenanwalt solltest
du genau festlegen, wie viel du an deine Familie
und Freunde verschenken willst.
Vielleicht so um die 20%.
Das wären in unserem einfachen Rechenbeispiel
20 Millionen Euro und sollte wahrscheinlich
reichen, um deine Liebsten abzusichern.
So musst du dich nicht mit der Frage auseinandersetzen,
ob du deinem Onkel Jürgen 20.000 Euro für
den Start seines Aquarium-Fachhandels oder
was auch immer, schenken möchtest.
Du hast vorher festgelegt wieviel du Jürgen
gibst.
Was er damit macht, ist seine Sache.
Du bist also fein aus dem Schneider.
Noch weihst du aber keinen in deiner Familie
in diese Schritte ein.
Die Auszahlung übernimmt dann später dein
neuer Anwalt.
Sobald das geschafft ist, triffst du auf deinen
schlimmsten Widersacher.
Dich Selber!
Eine große Menge Geld kann Sicherheit und
Unabhängigkeit für den Rest deines Lebens
bedeuten, aber du wirst in den nächsten Monaten
erfahren, dass man Geld sehr schnell ausgeben kann.
Was ist schon hier und da ne Million, wenn
man noch 80 Millionen hat?
Du musst dir also ein Sicherheitsnetz aufbauen.
Zahle am besten weitere 20% deines Gewinns
direkt ein und regel vertraglich, dass du
nur in Notsituationen und immer nur auf einen
Teil dieses Geldes zugreifen kannst.
Das sorgt dafür, dass du da nicht so einfach
rankommst.
Dieses Geld ist nicht zum verprassen, investieren
oder verschenken.
Das ist deine Altersvorsorge.
50% der Summe lässt du für dich investieren
und anlegen.
Dein Anwalt wird dich vermitteln können und
auch aufpassen, dass du hier nicht über den
Tisch gezogen wirst.
Die Profis sollen dein Vermögen möglichst
sicher, breit und langfristig für dich anlegen.
Denn selbst bei schlechten Zinsen wirst du
jährlich genug Geld erwirtschaften, um mehr als locker
über die Runden zu kommen.
Mit jährlichen Zinsen von 4% würdest du
zum Beispiel jeden Monat 166.000€ bekommen.
Klar, darauf muss man dann noch Steuern zahlen,
aber dieses Geld bekommst du jeden Monat für
den Rest deines Lebens.
Und dein eigentliches Vermögen wird dabei   nicht
weniger, weil du ja von den Zinsen lebst.
Jetzt wo du dich um Freunde und Familie, dein
monatliches Einkommen und eine Altersvorsorge
für Notfälle gekümmert hast, wird es endlich
Zeit deinen Gewinn entgegen zu nehmen.
Und wenn du hier nicht gut aufpasst, kannst
du ein riesiges Problem bekommen.
In der gesamten EU kann man Gewinne anonym
annehmen.
Nimm von diesem Recht auf jeden Fall gebrauch!
Das kann ich nicht deutlich genug sagen.
In China zum Beispiel, muss man die Gewinne
öffentlich und persönlich abholen.
Was dafür gesorgt hat, dass Kostüme wie
diese ganz hier normal sind.
Das Letzte was man mit seinem Vermögen tun
sollte, ist jedem zu erzählen, dass man es
hat.
Deswegen ist es auch so wichtig, dass erst
einmal niemand etwas von deinem Gewinn weiß.
Und das führt mich zu meinem letzten und
vielleicht wichtigsten Ratschlag.
Warte ein ganzes Jahr ab, bis du irgendetwas
davon in die Tat umsetzt.
Das hat mehrere Gründe.
Zum einen wird, trotz des Gesetzes, dass du
deinen Gewinn anonym annehmen darfst, immer
gesagt, aus welcher Region der Gewinner kommt.
Manche Menschen können zwei und zwei zusammenzählen
und werden es bemerken, wenn du eine Woche
nach dem Lotto-Jackpot mit einem nagelneuen
Sportwagen rumfährst.
Der andere Grund ist aber vielleicht noch
wichtiger: Man braucht Zeit, um sich an den
Gedanken zu gewöhnen Millionär zu sein.
Denk in Ruhe über alles nach und versuch
für dich herauszufinden, was dich wirklich
glücklich macht.
Was du tun möchtest.
Du musst nie wieder in deinem Leben arbeiten,
aber den ganzen Tag in deiner Villa zu hocken und Fernsehen
zu gucken und PlayStation zu spielen macht
nicht jahrzehntelang Spaß.
Du hast jetzt eine unglaubliche Freiheit.
Und damit auch den Fluch, dass du für dein
eigenes Glück verantwortlich bist.
Jim Carrey hat mal gesagt: “Ich wünsche
mir, dass jeder Mensch reich und berühmt
wird, damit sie sehen können, dass es nicht
die Antwort ist.”
Eine Studie zum Thema Glück aus dem Jahr
1978 hat 22 Lotterie-Gewinner mit 29 Menschen
verglichen, die bei einem Unfall gelähmt
wurden.
Wie zu erwarten sind die Lotteriegewinner
zu Beginn sehr viel glücklicher als die Kontrollgruppe,
während die gelähmten Menschen unglücklicher
waren.
Doch schon nach einem Jahr haben sich beide
Gruppen wieder der Kontrollgruppe angenähert.
Die Gelähmten fanden Möglichkeiten in ihrer
neuen Situation Spaß zu haben und die Lotto-Gewinner
gewöhnten sich Stück für Stück an ihr
Geld.
Und auch wenn man die Studie wegen ihrer kleine
Stichprobengröße nicht als wissenschaftlichen
Fakt ansehen sollte, hilft sie doch zu versinnbildlichen,
dass Geld alleine nicht glücklich macht.
Wer jetzt genau nachgerechnet hat, dem wird
aufgefallen sein, dass noch 10% des Gewinns
übrig sind.
Diese 10 Millionen darfst du auf den Kopf
hauen.
Kauf dir ein geiles Auto, ein Boot oder eine
Villa, spende das Geld oder bau dir eine Firma auf.
Egal was du machst,
hab Spaß dabei. Denn du hast immerhin im
Lotto gewonnen.
Ok, das ist natürlich ein spannendes Gedankenspiel.
Aber machen wir uns nichts vor.
Lotto ist letztendlich Glücksspiel.
Und die Wahrscheinlichkeit, dass jemand von
euch im Lotto gewinnt ist verschwindend gering.
Der letzte Euro-Jackpot hatte eine Gewinnwahrscheinlichkeit
von 1 zu 95 Millionen.
Zusätzlich kann Glücksspiel süchtig machen
und hat schon viele Existenzen zerstört.
Die meisten Gewinner spielen wöchentlich,
und das schon Jahre lang.
Hättest du in den letzten 20 Jahren jede
Woche einen Lottoschein gekauft, dann läge
die Wahrscheinlichkeit in diesen 20 Jahren
einmal den Jackpot zu gewinnen immer noch
bei grob 1:200.000.
Gleichzeitig hast du in diesen 20 Jahren aber
über 11.000€ in Lottoscheine gesteckt.
Ein klares Verlustgeschäft.
Anstatt also wöchentlich 12€ für Lotto
auszugeben, wäre es für dich und deine Zukunft
besser das Geld anzulegen.
Wenn du in den letzten 20 Jahren jeden Monat
das Geld der vier Lottoscheine, also 48 Euro
investiert hättest, dann hättest du jetzt
knapp 30.000 Euro.
Hier hast du auch nur 11.000 investiert, der
Rest kommt durch die Zinsen deiner Anlagen.
Ihr seht also: Glücksspiel lohnt sich nicht.
Ihr werdet mit dem großen Geld geködert,
gewinnen werdet ihr aber mit sehr hoher wahrscheinlichkeit
nichts.
Wenn ihr aber unbedingt Geld ausgeben wollt,
dann gebt es nicht Organisationen, die die
Spielsucht von Menschen ausnutzen, sondern
spendet es an wohltätige Zwecke oder unterstützt zum Beispiel Inhalte, die Ihr gerne auf Youtube guckt.
Doktor Whatson hat,
ganz zufällig
Einen Patreon Account und wenn ihr da   3$ im
Monat spendet, dann werdet ihr hier unten
im Abspann erwähnt.
Ab 10$ könnt ihr schon Videos früher als
alle anderen gucken.
Link dazu ist unten in der Videobeschreibung.
Wie immer, vielen Dank fürs zuschauen und  bleibt neugierig, euer Cedric.
Cedric?
Hast du nicht letztens Lotto gespielt?
Ich hab gewonnen!
Ich kündige!
Ähm...
Ist das nicht deine Firma?